friendly greetings to everyone my name
is carol jolie and i promise to you that
the pronunciation of my name is going to
be the most complicated thing in this
unofficial talk this piece of work is a
collaboration between Activision
Blizzard the university of zaragoza and
the technical university of vienna the
quest here was to render images with
really high quality subsurface
scattering in real time on commodity
hardware normally to render
photorealistic images we populate a
scene with objects add the camera and
the light source and start tracing rays
from the camera to determine the
incoming gradients now even though there
is a large volume of research going on
on how to do this efficiently this is
still a really time-consuming process
what's more this figure here shows light
transport only between surfaces meaning
that we suppose that rays of light
propagate only in vacuum if we extend
our program to support participating
media we can render volumetric effects
like smoke case and many others and also
translucent materials such as skin plant
leaves marble wax and so on however this
extension pumps up the dimensionality of
the integral we need to solve making the
process even more time-consuming but a
reward for this is immense here on the
left you can see how our skin would look
like without subsurface scattering it is
indeed a very important factor in the
visual appearance of many translucent
materials it is not a surprise that the
motion picture and the game industries
are yearning for a real-time solution
for this there are fortunately
simplified models to render subsurface
light transport in optically thick
materials what we do here is take an
infinite half space of a chosen
translucent material light and
infinitesimally thin pencil beam from
above in normal incidence this beam will
penetrate the surface of the material
and you start to attenuate
it becomes more and more submerged into
the medium during this process these
photons undergo many scattering events
and eventually exit somewhere away from
the origin
counting up these photons exiting at
different distances we can build a
histogram that we call diffusion profile
and will denote as Rd this is an actual
simulated diffusion profile what it
looks like if we look from above another
important bit of preliminary knowledge
is that we can directly use these
diffusion profiles by convolving them
with an input irradiance map to add
subsurface scattering to it as a post
processing step this is how the result
looks like after the convolution is
applied now this is remarkable as we
don't have to run the fully rate race
simulation with participating media
however these signals are stored as
images so normally this means that we
compute a 2d convolution between them
unfortunately this is very costly but
there are techniques to reduce this
problem to several much cheaper 1d
convolutions one example is Dion's
excellent technique it takes into
consideration that in a homogeneous and
isotropic medium the diffusion profiles
are radially symmetric therefore it is
possible to take a 1d slice of this
profile as shown below here and trying
to fit it with a sum of gaussians which
are individually also radially symmetric
this means that we can use a cheaper set
of 1d convolutions instead of using the
2d profile directly this is an example
input signal and the results with Dion's
technique with different number of
gaussians compared to the true diffusion
kernel it is important to point out that
given the mathematical properties of
gaussians this technique requires warm
horizontal and one vertical convolution
for Gaussian
these are 1d convolutions this also
means that if we'd like to obtain
high-quality subsurface scattering we
need at least four Gaussian and
therefore 80 convolutions this is
suitable for most real-time applications
however it is a really smart idea and
hasn't been really improved since 2007
and honestly when we started this
project we didn't think anyone could
realistically come up with something
that's better than this our quest was
nonetheless to obtain high fidelity
results with a separable kernel using
only two convolutions which is marked
with green up there visualizing the SVD
of the diffusion profile it is clear
that signal is non-separable it is not
possible to write this 2d function as a
mere product of 1d functions however the
semi-log plot tells us that the
higher-ranked singular values became
rapidly meaning that most of the
information here is not random it has a
lot of structure therefore a Rank 1
approximation sounds like a good
starting point the plan was to treat the
diffusion profile here on the right as a
matrix for which we compute the SVD here
you can see the one singular value that
we're taking and the corresponding left
and right singular vectors that we here
denote by a we then compute one
horizontal and one vertical convolution
using these singular vectors to
reconstruct the diffusion kernel and
obtain the output this is the input and
the rank one SVD reconstruction this
would be the ground truth and now we can
see that the separable SVD approximation
is indeed looking very grim there is a
world of a difference between the two so
wow this is surprising especially
considering the fact that the eckhart
Young theorem teaches us that the SVD is
the best reconstruction in terms of the
Frobenius norm which corresponds here to
the RMS error this is the absolute best
reconstruction we can obtain with
respect to the RMS error very
disappointing here is the UN's algorithm
the one with the 1d slice and fitting
with one gaussian this means the same
amount of convolutions and hence the
same execution time as the rain
on SVD and the ground truth this is how
the SVD looks like on the real world
scene compared to using the true kernel
looking at it again in our
disappointment we notice that the SVD
yields an overall darker image therefore
the reconstruction is not energy
conserving a new idea came up maybe we
would try this before putting the
project on ice and calling it a day what
if we would solve a minimization problem
where the reconstructed kernel would
still be as close as possible to the
diffusion profile but would also be
energy conserving this should definitely
be a valuable option and the results are
dreadful horrendous I just I just don't
know what to say look at the lows
somehow as if the input the irradiance
signal showed up as an really nasty
ringing artifact and we had the same
around the ear we visualize the actual
kernel on a disk of light to see what
went wrong here and yes we see that it
is indeed trapped full nothing like the
simulated diffusion kernel
but we hadn't the slightest idea why
this happened
visualizing the kernel itself in a
simple 1d plot and staring at it for a
while it looks like a great separable
approximation with respect to the RMS
error
most of the energy of the signal is
close to the origin and the optimizer
tries to reconstruct these details as
closely as possible please note that the
kernel plots are deceiving these signals
indeed have the same amount of energy
but the tale of the fit is extending
really far away and this makes up for
the seemingly less energy of the signal
this very delicate thing too could wake
up my life and I kind of want it back so
what if we would minimize not only the
RMS error by itself which forces the
optimizer to concentrate the energy to
the origin of the signal where the
energy spike is but we would add a guide
function which behaves like an envelope
that tells the optimizer to possibly
reconstruct regions not close to the
origin but focus a bit more on far in
scattering this is the fit we originally
had and this is a very simple distance
weighted guide function I had in mind
imagine that we now have a more general
model for which we used K equals 0 a
constant envelope to obtain these
horrendous results I will now tell the
optimizer to use K equals 1 which means
that we would give higher waste to the
regions further away from the origin
this is what we obtained very intuitive
we have a signal with the same amount of
energy as if we pushed it from the top
to neglect the origin and add this
energy to the tail of the signal to
focus on the reconstruction of four
rings scattering and now we can even go
k equals 2 which is essentially
squishing the signal a bit more to
emphasize foreign scattering at the
price of neglecting sharp close range
details back to the original fit let's
wait it by distance a bit by plugging K
equals 1 in the optimizer all
there okay let's go Kay close to a bit
more emphasis on firing scattering
now this looks remarkably close to the
ground truth this is the journey behind
the guided optimization technique that
is separable requires only two
convolutions and is one of the
techniques we propose for applications
with strict real time time constraints
we also propose an other technique which
we have mathematically derived and for
which I admit not having an intuitive
story
so before I dare showing you the next
slide take a big breath and let's go
so sorry this is how it looks like and
what is remarkable about it that this
follows a completely different paradigm
what we're aiming for here is not to
make our kernel close to the original
diffusion kernel but trying to make the
result of the convolution the same it is
almost like minimizing the l2 distance
of the resulting convolved images not
the kernels themselves spinning for
images not kernels this is impossible to
solve for a general case so in order to
accomplish this one needs to confine the
solution to a class of input irradiance
signals input images where it would work
well in our derivation we plugged in 1d
signals as inputs this means that the
technique should behave analytically on
signals like this and the most
remarkable thing that this is a mere
rank one separable approximation that is
really analytic for this class of
signals this means that it mimics the
effect of the true kernel perfectly
let's take a look at this on a practical
case of course not all signals are 1
these signals
this's our result with the analytic
pre-integrated kernel and the ground
truth very close to being
indistinguishable furthermore it is
really simple to implement and it has a
closed form solution that does not
require any kind of optimization
procedure one more interesting detail
for the more curious minds
this technique is analytic for a greater
class than only one these signals a
class that we call additively separable
signals so what about artistic editing
the pre-integrated technique is great
but it does not offer any kind of
artistic control over the output the
guided approximation requires
optimization but in return it also
offers some degree of artistic freedom
on how the desired outputs should look
like we also have this technique which
is simply using two separable gaussians
of different variance values one each to
provide perfect artistic freedom in
adjusting the magnitudes of close and
foreign scattering note that these two
gaussians are not the same as indians
approach with the two gaussians as we
don't use the radially symmetric one
this signal directly a real-world
example this is the input irradiance
heavily exaggerated for in scattering
have any exaggerated close-range
scattering and the more conservative
really good-looking mixture of the two
wrapping it up the SVD is great for
applications that can afford higher rank
reconstructions the kernel pre
integration is a simple technique that
is analytic for additively separable
signals guided optimization a more
general version of the pre integration
that can be conveniently tuned with one
parameter manual approximation many
degrees of freedom for artists while it
has a quite reasonable accuracy that is
comparable to for gaussians with
previous techniques different techniques
with different levels of scientific
rigor and different target audiences
ranging from scientists
two artists working in the industry now
even though we used examples with skin
to demonstrate our techniques it is
important to point out that they work
for a variety of translucent media such
as plants marble fruits in this still
life and milk the most important
take-home message from this project at
least for me is that it's entirely
possible to do academic research
together with companies and create
results that can make it to
multi-million dollar computer games but
also having proven results that are
useful for the scientific community
thank you